the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well because our subject today is trig
integrals and substitutions professor
jerison called in his substitute teacher
for today that's me professor Miller and
I'm going to try to tell you about trig
trig substitutions and trig integrals
and I'll be here tomorrow to do more of
the same as well
so this is about trigonometry and maybe
the first thing I'll do is remind you of
some basic things about trigonometry
so if I have a circle
well trigonometry is all based on this
circle of radius 1 and centered at the
origin and so if this is an angle of
theta up from the x-axis then the
coordinates of this point are cosine
theta and sine theta and so that leads
right away to some trig identities which
you know very well but I'm going to put
them up here because we'll use them over
and over again today remember the
convention sine squared of theta
secretly means sine of theta quantity
squared it would be more sensible to
write a parenthesis around the sine of
theta and then say you square that but
everybody in the world puts the 2 up
there over the sine and so I'll do that
too so that follows just because the
circle has radius 1 but then there are
some other identities too which I think
you remember I'll write them down here
cosine of 2 theta there's this double
angle formula that says cosine of 2
theta is cosine squared of theta minus
the sine squared of theta and there's
also the double angle formula for the
sine of 2 theta remember what that says
two sine theta cosine theta now I'm
going to use these trig identities and
I'm going to use them in a slightly
different way and so I'd like to pay a
little more attention to this one and
get some more get a different way of
writing this one out so this is the
actually the half angle formula and that
says I'm going to try to express the
cosine of theta in terms of the cosine
of two theta so if I know the cosine of
two theta I want to try to express the
cosine of theta in terms of it yeah well
I'll start with the cosine of two theta
and play with that
okay well we know what this is it's
cosine squared theta minus the sine
squared of theta but we also know what
the sine squared of theta is in terms of
the cosine so I can eliminate the sine
squared from this picture so this is
equal to the cosine squared of theta
minus the quantity one minus cosine
square root of theta I put in what sine
squared is in terms of cosine squared
and so that's twice the cosine squared
of theta minus one there's this cosine
squared which gets a plus sign because
of these two minus signs and there's the
one that was there before so altogether
there are two of them I want to isolate
what cosine is or rather what cosine
squared is so let's solve for that so
I'll put the 1 on the other side and I
get 1 plus cosine of 2 theta and then I
want to divide by this 2 and so that
puts a 2 in this denominator here so
some people call that the half angle
formula it's a way of experience is it's
a way of eliminating powers from sines
and cosines I've gotten rid of the
square at the expense of putting in a 2
theta here we'll use that and similarly
same calculation shows that the sine
squared of theta is 1 minus cosine of 2
theta divided by 2 same cosine in that
formula also but it has a minus sign for
the sine squared okay so that's my
little review of trig identities that
will make use of as this this lecture
goes on I want to talk about trig
identity trig integrals and you know
some trig integrals I'm sure already
like well let me write the differential
form first you know that D sine theta or
maybe I'll say D sine X
is let's see that's the derivative of
sine x times DX right the derivative of
sine X is cosine of X DX and so if I
integrate both sides here the integral
form of this is the integral of the
cosine of X DX is the sine of X plus a
constant and the same way the cosine of
X is minus the sine of X DX right the
derivative of the cosine is minus the
sine and when I integrate that I find
the integral of the sine of X DX is
minus the cosine of X plus C so that's
our starting point and the game today
for the first half of the lecture is to
use that basic that was just those basic
integration formulas together with
clever use of trig identities in order
to compute more complicated formulas
involving trig functions so the first
thing the first topic is to think about
integrals of the form sine to the nth
power of X cosine to the nth power of X
DX where here I have in mind him and n
are positive non-negative integers so
let's try to integrate these I'll show
you some applications of these pretty
soon looking down the road a little bit
integrals like this show up in Fourier
series and many other subjects in
mathematics it turns out they're quite
important to be able to do so that's why
we're doing them now well so there are
two two cases to think about here if
when you're integrating things like this
there's the easy case and let's do that
one first the easy case just when at
least one exponent is odd
that's the easy case so for example
suppose that I wanted to integrate well
let's take the case M equals 1 so I'm
integrating sine to the nth power of X
times the cosine of X DX I'm taking oh I
could do that one let's see if that's
what I want to take yeah the can my
confusion is that I meant to have this a
different power you were thinking that
so let's do this case when M is 1 so the
integral I'm trying to do is any power
of the sine times the cosine well here's
the trick recognize use this formula up
at the top there to see cosine of X DX
as something that we already have on the
blackboard so the way to look to exploit
that is to make a substitution
substitution is going to be U is the
sine of X and here's Y then this
integral that I'm trying to do is the
integral of U to the N that's already a
simplification and then there's that
cosine of X times DX
when you make a substitution you've got
to go all the way and replace everything
in the expression by things involved
involving this new variable that I've
introduced so I'd better get rid of the
cosine of X DX and rewrite it in terms
of D U or in terms of U and I can do
that because D u according to that
formula is the cosine of X
DX let me put a box around that that's
our substitution when you make a
substitution you also want to compute
the differential of the variable that
you substitute in so the so the cosine
of X DX that appears here is just
exactly D U and I've replaced this trig
integral with something that doesn't
involve trig functions at all
this is a lot easier we can just plug in
to what we know here this is U to the n
plus one over n plus one plus a constant
and I've done the integral but I'm not
quite done with the problem yet because
to be nice to your reader and to
yourself you should go back at this
point probably go back and get rid of
this new variable that you introduced
you're the one who introduced this
variable u nobody except you really
knows what it is right but the rest of
the world knows what they asked for in
the first place
that involved X so I have to go back and
get rid of this and that's not hard to
do in this case because U is the sine of
X and so I make this back substitution
and that's what you get so there's the
answer ok so the game was I use this odd
power of the cosine here and I could see
it appearing as the differential of the
sine so that's what made this
substitution work let's do another
example to see how that works out in a
slightly different case
so here's another example okay now I do
have an odd power one of the exponents
is odd so I'm in the easy case but it's
not one okay the game now is to use to
use this this trig identity to get rid
of the largest even power that you can
from this odd power here so use sine
square root of x it's 1 minus the cosine
square root of x to eliminate a lot of
powers from that odd power
watch what happens so this is not a
really a substitution or anything this
is just a trig identity this sine cubed
is sine squared times the sine and sine
squared is 1 minus the cosine squared of
X and then I have the remaining sine of
X and then I have cosine squared of X DX
so let me rewrite that a little bit to
see how this works out this is the
integral of cosine squared of X minus
and then there's the product of these
two that's cosine to the fourth of x
times the sine of X DX so now I'm really
exactly in the situation that I was in
over here I've got a single power of a
trick of a sine or cosine it happens
that it's a sign here but that's not
going to cause any trouble we can go
ahead and play the same trick same game
that I did there so so far I've just
been using trig identities but now I'll
use a trig substitution
and I think I want to write these as
powers of a variable and then this is
going to be the differential of that
variable so I'll take you to be cosine
of X and that means the D U is minus
sine of X DX
there's the substitution and so when I
make that substitution what do we get
cosine squared becomes u squared cosine
to the fourth becomes U to the fourth
and sine of X DX becomes not quite d you
watch for the Signum watch for this
minus sign here it becomes minus D u but
that's okay the minus sign comes outside
and I can integrate both of these powers
so I get minus u ki minus u cubed over
three and then this fourth power gives
me a fifth power when I integrate and
don't forget the constant am I done not
quite done I have to back substitute and
get rid of my choice of variable U and
replace it with yours questions
there should indeed I forgot this minus
sign when I came down here so these two
gang up to give me a plus so that's what
the other question is about - thanks so
let's back substitute and I'm going to
put that over here and the result is
well I just replaced the U by cosine of
X so this is minus cosine cubed of X
over 3 plus thank you cosine 2 v of x
over 5 plus a constant there's the
answer by the way you can remember one
of the nice things about doing an
integral is it's fairly easy to check
your answer you can always differentiate
the thing you get and see whether you
get the right thing when you go back
it's not too hard to use the power rules
and the differentiation rule for the
cosine to get back to this if you if you
want to check the work let's do one more
example just to take handle a case an
example of this easy case which you
might not have thought of it for at
first suppose I just want to integrate a
cube sine cubed of X no cosine in sight
but I do have an odd power of a of a
trig function of a sine or cosine so I'm
in the easy case and the the procedure
that I was suggesting says I want to
take out the largest even power that I
can from the sine cubed so I'll take
that out that's a sine squared and write
it as 1 minus cosine squared well now
I'm very happy because it's just like
the situation we had somewhere on the
board here it's just like the situation
we had up here I've got a power of a
cosine times sine of X DX so exactly the
same substitution steps in you get
and maybe you can see what happens
without doing doing the work shall I do
the work here I'll make the same
substitution and so this is one minus u
squared times minus D U which is u minus
u cube over 3 but then I want to put
this minus sign in place so that gives
me minus u plus u cubed over 3 plus a
constant
and then I back substitute and get
cosine of X plus cosine cubed of x over
3 so this is the easy case if you have
some odd power to play with then you can
make use of it and it's pretty
straightforward
ok the harder case is when you don't
have an odd power so what's the program
I'm going to do the harder case and then
I'm going to show you an example of how
to integrate square roots and do an
application using these ideas from
trigonometry so I want to keep this
blackboard maybe I'll come back and
start here again
so the harder case is when they're only
even exponents
I'm still trying to integrate the same
form but now all the exponents are even
so we have to do some gain and here the
game is use the half angle formula which
I've just erased very sadly on the board
here maybe I'll rewrite them over here
so we have them on the board I think I
remember what they were
okay so the game is I'm going to use
that half angle formula to start getting
rid of those even powers half angle
formula written like this exactly is
going to talks about it rewrites even
powers of sines and cosines so let's see
any how that works out in an example how
about just the cosine squared for for a
start what to do I can't pull pull
anything out I could rewrite this as 1
minus cosine squared but then I'd be
faced with integrating the sine squared
which is exactly as hard so instead
let's use this formula here this is
really the same as 1 plus the cosine of
2 theta over 2 and now this is easy it's
got two parts to it
integrating one half gives me theta over
Oh miraculously the X turn into a theta
let's put it back as X I get x over 2 by
integrating 1/2
F so notice that something non
trigonometric occurs here when I do
these even integrals x over two appears
and then the other one okay so this
takes a little thought the integral of
the cosine is the sine there's it minus
the sine negative sign okay so we take a
vote I think it's positive so you get
the sine of 2x but is that right over -
if I differentiate the sine of 2x this
two comes out and would give me an extra
two here so it's there's an extra two
that I have to put in here when I
integrate it and there's the answer this
is not a substitution I just played with
trig identities here and then did a
simple trig integral getting your help
to get the sine right and thinking about
what this two is going to do it produces
a 2 in the denominator but it's not
applying any any complicated thing it's
just using this identity all right let's
do another example that's a little bit
harder this time sine squared times
cosine squared
again no odd powers I've got to work a
little bit harder and what I'm going to
do is apply those identities up there
now what I recommend doing in this
situation is going over to the side
somewhere and do some side work because
it's all just playing with trig
functions it's not actually doing any
integrals it for a while so I guess one
way to get rid of the sine squared and
the cosine squared is to use those
identities and so let's do that so the
sine is 1 minus the cosine of 2 x over
two and the cosine is 1 plus the cosine
2x over 2 so I just substitute them in
and now I can multiply that out and it's
not what I have is a difference times a
product
sorry difference times a sum so you know
a formula for that getting taking the
product of these two things well there
will be 4 in the denominator and then in
the numerator yet I get the square of
this minus the square of this right a
minus B times a plus B is a squared
minus B squared so I get that well I'm a
little bit happier because at least I
don't have 4 I don't have 2 different
squares I still have a square I want to
integrate this I'm still not in the easy
case I got myself back to an easier hard
case ok but we do know what to do about
this because I just did it up there and
I could play into this formula that we
got but I think it's just as easy to
start to continue to calculate here use
the half angle formula again for this
and continue on your way so I get a
quarter from this
bit and then minus a quarter of the
cosine squared of 2x okay now when I
plug in two x in for theta they're in
the top Ward I'm going to get a four X
on the right-hand side so it comes out
like that
and I guess I could simplify that a
little bit more this is a quarter oh but
then there's a two here it's half that
so then I can simplify a little more
it's a quarter minus 1/8 which is 1/8
and then I have 1/8 of cosine of 4x okay
that's my side work I just did some trig
identities over here and rewrote sine
squared times cosine squared as
something which involves just no powers
of trig just cosine by itself and a
constant so I can take that and
substitute it in here and now the
integration is pretty easy 1/8 cosine of
4x over 8 DX which is okay the 1/8 is
going to give me x over 8 the integral
of cosine is plus or minus the sine the
derivative of the sine is plus the
cosine so it's going to be plus the only
there's a minus here so it's going to be
the sine minus the sine 4x divided by
this 8 but then I have an additional
factor in the denominator and what's it
going to be I have to put a 4 there
so we've done that calculation too so
any of these if you if you keep doing
this kind of process these these two
kinds of procedures any any you can you
you can now integrate any expression
that has a power of a sign times the
power of a cosine in it by using these
ideas now let's see olya let me give you
an alternate method for for this last
one here I know what I'll do
let me give an alternate method for
doing really doing the side work over
there I'm trying to deal with sine
squared times cosine squared well that's
the square that's the square of the sine
of X times the cosine of X and the sine
of X times the cosine of X shows up
right here in another trig identity so
we can make use of that too that reduces
the number of factors of sines and
cosines by one so it's going in the
right direction this is equal to 1/2
sine of two x squared right sine times
cosine is 1/2 so this right it's sine of
two x over two and then I want to square
that so what I get is the sine squared
of 2 x over 4
which is well I'm not too happy yet
because I still have an even power
remember I'm trying to integrate this
thing in the end even powers are bad I
try to get rid of them by using that
formula for the half-angle formula so I
can apply that to the sine of X here
again I get 1/4 of 1 minus the cosine of
4x divided by 2 that's what the half
angle formula says for the sine squared
of 2x and that's exactly the same as the
expression that I got up here as well
it's the same expression that I have
there so it's the same expression as I
have here so this is just an alternate
way to play this game of using the half
angle formula okay let's do a little
application of these things and change
the change the topic a little bit
so here's the problem so this is an
application and example of a real trig
substitution so here's the problem I
want to look at okay so I have a circle
whose radius is a and I cut out from it
a sort of tab here this tab here and the
height of this thing is B so that this
this length is a number B and what I
want to do is compute the area of that
little tab that's the problem so there's
an arc over here and that's what I want
if I want to find the area of this for
for a and B in terms of a and B so the
area well I guess one way to compute the
area would be to take the integral of Y
DX
I think you've you've seen the idea of
splitting this up into vertical strips
whose height is given by a function y of
X and then you integrate that that's an
interpretation for the integral the area
is given by y DX but that's a little bit
awkward because my formula for y is
going to be a little strange it's
constant value of B along here and then
at this point it becomes this arc of the
circle so working this out I could do it
but it's a little awkward because
expressing Y is a function of X the top
edge of this shape it's a little awkward
and takes two different regions to
express so a different way
to say it is to say X dy maybe that'll
work a little bit better or maybe it
won't but it's worth trying I could just
as well split this region up into
horizontal strips whose width is dy and
whose length is X now I'm thinking of
this as a function of Y this is the
graph of a function of Y and that's much
better because the function of Y is well
it's the square root of a squared minus
y squared isn't it that's a squared plus
x squared plus y squared equals a
squared so that's what X is and that's
when I'm asked to integrate then the
square root of a squared minus y squared
dy and I can even put in limits of
integration maybe I should do that
because this is supposed to be an actual
number
I guess I'm integrating it from y equals
zero that's here to y equals b dy so
this is what I want to find this is a
formula an integral formula for the area
of that region and this is a new form I
don't think that the you've thought
about integrating expressions like this
in this class before so it's a new form
and I want to show you how to do it how
it's related to trigonometry well it's
it's related to trigonometry through
that exact picture that we have on the
blackboard after all this a squared
minus y squared is the quick formula for
this arc and so what I propose is that
we try to try to exploit the connection
with the circle and introduce polar
coordinates so here if I take and
measure this angle then there are
various things you can say like the
coordinates of this point here are
a cosine theta hey well I'm sorry it's
not that's an angle but I want to call
it theta zero and in general know that
the coordinates of this pointer a cosine
theta a sine theta if the egg if the
radius is is a and the angle here is
Theta so X is cosine of is a cosine
theta and Y is a sine theta just from
looking at the geometry of the circle so
let's make that substitution y equals a
sine theta I'm using the picture to
suggest that maybe making this
substitution is a good thing to do let's
follow along and see what happens if
that's true what we're interested in is
integrating a squared minus y squared
which is a squared interested in
integrating the square root of a squared
minus y squared which is the square root
of a squared minus this a squared sine
squared theta and well that's the square
root that's equal to a times the cosine
of theta right
that's just a sketch that's just sine
squared plus cosine squared equals one
all over again it's also X this is ax
and this was X so they're doing a lot of
different ways to think of this but no
matter how you say it the thing we're
trying to integrate a squared minus y
squared is in under this substitution it
is a cosine of theta so I'm interested
in integrating the square root of a
squared minus y squared dy and I'm going
to make this substitution Y is a times
the sine of theta and so under that
substitution
I've decided that the square root of a
squared minus y squared is a cosine
theta
that's this what about the dy
well I better compute the D Y so dy just
differentiating this expression is a
cosine theta D theta so let's put that
in dy is a cosine theta D theta okay
making that trig substitution y equals a
sine theta has replaced this integral
that has a square root in it and no trig
functions with an integral that involves
no square roots and only trig functions
in fact it's not too hard to integrate
this now because of the work that we've
done the a squared comes out this is
cosine squared theta D theta and maybe
we've done that example already today I
think we have maybe we can think it
through but maybe the easiest thing is
to look back at notes and see what we
got before that was the first example in
the hard case that I did and what it
came out to I used X instead of theta at
the time
okay so we've this is good step forward
I started with this integral that I
really didn't know how to do by any
means that we've had so far and I've
replaced it by a trig integral that we
do know how to do and now I've done that
trig integral but we're still not quite
done because of the problem of back
substituting I'd like to go back and
rewrite this in terms of of the original
variable Y or I'd like to go back and
rewrite it in terms of the original
limits of integration that we had in the
original problem in doing that it's
going to be useful to rewrite this
expression and get rid of the sine of
two theta after all the original Y was
expressed in terms of the sine of theta
not the sine of two theta so let me just
do that here and say that this in turn
is equal to a squared beta over 2 plus
well the sine of two theta is twice the
sine of theta times the cosine of theta
and so when there's a 4 in the
denominator what I'll get is sine of
theta cosine of theta over 2 I'm did
that because I because I'm getting
closer to the original terms that the
problem started with which was sine of
theta
okay so let me write down the integral
that we have now the square root of a
squared minus y squared dy is so far
what we know is a squared theta over two
plus sine theta cosine theta over two
plus C but I want to go back and rewrite
this in terms of the original value the
original variable Y well what is theta
in terms of Y let's see Y in terms of
theta was given like this so what is
theta in terms of Y ah
so here the fearsome arc sine rears its
head right
theta is the angle so that y equals a
the sine of theta so that means that
theta is the arc sine or sine inverse of
well Y divided by a so that's what
that's the first thing that shows up
here arc sine of Y over a all over two
that's this term theta is the arc sine
of Y over a / - what about the other
side here well sine and cosine we knew
what they were in terms of Y and in
terms of X if you like sine is a oh is
actually maybe I'll put the a squared
inside here that makes a little bit
nicer plus and then the other term is a
squared sine of theta cosine of theta
so the a times sine of theta is just Y
maybe I'll write this a
sine of theta a cosine of theta over two
plus C and so I get the same thing and
now here a sine of theta that's why and
what's the a times the cosine of theta
it's X or if you like it's the square
root of Y a a squared minus y squared
and so there I've rewritten everything
back in terms of the original variable Y
and there's an answer so I've done this
indefinite integration of of a form in
of this quadratic this square root of
something which is a constant minus y
squared whenever you see that the thing
to think of is trigonometry that's going
to play into the sine squared plus
cosine squared identity and the way to
exploit it is to make the substitution y
equals a sine of theta you could also
make a substitution y equals a cosine of
theta if you wanted to and the result
would come out to be exactly the same in
the end
I'm still not quite done with the
original problem that I had because
because the original problem asked for a
definite integral so let's just go back
and finish that as well
so the area was the integral from 0 to B
of the square root so I just want to
evaluate the right hand side here the
answer that we came up with this
indefinite integral I want to evaluate
it at 0 and it'd be well let's see when
I evaluated it B I get a squared times
the arc sine of of of B over a over 2
plus y which is B times the square root
of a squared minus B squared putting y
equal to B divided by 2 so I've plugged
in y equals B into that formula this is
what I get then when I plug in y equals
0 well the sine of 0 is 0 so the arc
sine of 0 is 0 so this term goes away
and when Y is equal to 0 this term is 0
also and so I don't get any subtracted
terms at all so there's an expression
for this notice that this arc sine of B
over a that's exactly this angle the arc
sine of B over a it's the angle that you
get when y equals B so this theta is the
arc sine of B over a put this over here
that is theta zero that is the angle
that the corner makes so I could rewrite
this as a squared theta zero divided by
two plus B times the square root of a
squared minus B squared over two let's
just think about this for a minute
I have these two terms in the sum is
that reasonable the first term is a
squared that's the radius squared times
this angle times 1/2 well I think that
is exactly the area of the sector a
squared theta over 2 is the formula for
the area of the sector and this one this
is the vertical elevation this is the
horizontal B school a squared minus B
squared is this distance square root of
a squared minus B squared so the
right-hand term is B times the square
root of a squared minus B squared
divided by 2 that's the area of that
triangle so using a little bit of
geometry gives you the same answer as
all of this elaborate calculus maybe
that's enough cause for celebration for
us to quit for today